GUEST SPEAKER 1: IR bike lock.
GUEST SPEAKER 2:
Or... an IR light,
so we just combined
it all into one.
So if you want to
unlock this remotely
and you hit the
wrong button, you're
going to get blinking lights.
Nothing's going to happen.
But if you want to actually
unlock it, you aim.
The light goes on
so you can see.
And now you've
unlocked your bike.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: And
then you can lock it.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: If you
want to lock it back up--
[CLICK]
--light goes off, and you'll--
GUEST SPEAKER 1: And
the other buttons
are kind of reminiscent
of if someone
using the different key or
different remote control,
it's not the right one.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So nothing
else will set it off.
[APPLAUSE]
GUEST SPEAKER 3: If
you push a button,
it sends the specific hex code.
So if we program in--
if we program, the program
takes up the right hex code,
then it will open up and close.
PROFESSOR: There's
a IR tech standard.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: Yeah.
So there's specific
libraries for each remote.
And as long as you have
that library installed,
it'll understand
each you've sent in.
GUEST SPEAKER 1:
But the easiest way
to figure out what the
hex code is, is just
shining it on, putting
it on the serial monitor
and figuring out
what the hex code is.
We also built a emitter,
but it wasn't as nice.
So we just decided to go
with the preset remote.
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: It did work
at one point in time as well.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: We
know that struggle.